at the time it was made saw seven was to
be the final chapter of the soft
franchise and in honor of the series it
would bring back old characters old
locations
old music old tricks and old tracks but
i just want to know what happened to the
old that dog guy from saw two
we're gonna get into all of the saw
series callbacks that are in this movie
and there are a lot of them but first
let's talk about something new
for the first time the opening trap
takes place out in public during the day
rather than in a dark abandoned cellar
of some kind the characters find
themselves in a display window for a
store called welthammer judging by the
style this is a thousand percent were
found flick shops and in one wide shot
we see their slogan renovating your life
which i think fits nicely with the goal
of jigsaw to rehabilitate the lives of
his test subjects he was way ahead of
his time
teaching young men the dangers of
getting simped the same woman
has played each of you for a fool
manipulating your love for her and
causing
nothing but pain she is toxic now i saw
james's kill count and upon mention of
the word toxic he put a britney spears
sound
bite so uh i'm gonna one-up him
and honestly this is probably the
happiest ending of any sawtrap and
hoffman retires to his new hideout which
contains a variety of secrets
welcome to things you missed i tend to
refer to the original seven saw movies
as
the saw saga so here we are at the end
of it the saw movies were long time
kings of the october box office there
was even a marketing phrase that went if
it's halloween
it must be but saw six was actually
beaten in 2009 by paranormal activity
and saw six's director
kevin gruter was supposed to direct
paranormal activity too which would go
head-to-head with saw7 so the studio
said
you know what you're contractually
obligated to do another movie for us
you can't do paranormal too so kevin
gruchert said fine but i'm gonna change
a bunch of stuff last minute and it's
gonna suck
fine fine but we're shooting in 3d
[Music]
hoffman's hideout is filled with the
stuff we've come to expect to find in a
jigsaw workshop
billy's piggies and mannequins this
mannequin could be wearing the prototype
of the harness that dina wears in the
opening trap i've pointed out clues
about the location of the saw saga
throughout this series and most evidence
has pointed to the setting being a
fictional version of newark new jersey
while others seem to point
towards new york city the newscast
mentions a storm hitting the east coast
but hoffman's driver's license looks to
be more inspired by a new york id
unlike the license plates which seem to
be more new jersey one thing's for sure
that's gonna be a disgusting omelette
also the money that he's putting in his
bag at the end of the movie says bank of
new york on it so
take that as you will the tv mentioned
seven survivors found from the zoo game
of the last movie but by my count we've
only got six pamela jenkins brent abbott
tara abbott
addie emily and shelby unless they're
counting jill tuck but she wasn't
actually part of the game
so i don't really get that another point
that i mentioned about the location in
the last video was that the tv station
starts with the letter w which signifies
a channel in the eastern united states
whereas k
means western states the tv station
where bobby degan has his talk show
appearance is kwga tv
so i think he filmed the interview in
another city shortly before traveling
back across the country for the survivor
support group the host actually does
mention that he's on a national tour
welcome back we're live with bobby dagin
whose
national tour survive my story of
overcoming jigsaw rolls into town
this weekend she's also got a buddha
statue on her set just like the one seen
by john's death bed in saw three but
what's more interesting about this talk
show is the title of it
daybreak with donna evans the previous
year there were a number of horror
movies distributed by lion's gate one of
which was called daybreakers which was a
pretty good vampire movie with just one
part that just
i'm gonna roll the clip
another thing that's very interesting
about this and completely unplanned is
that daybreakers was directed by peter
and michael spirit who would eventually
be the ones to bring the sauce series
back from the dead pun intended in 2017
with jigsaw this is the point where saw7
does another thing
that the series has never really done
before and shows us a dream sequence
which i'm not crazy about because the
series has been kind of grounded in
reality for the first six entries so
why are we doing this now what i do find
interesting about this trap which is
called the pan train
is its possible connection to spiral we
see the signature jigsaw spiral on this
device and although this is just a
nightmare maybe jill had this bad dream
based off of a real trap idea that she
found in his workshop spiral's not out
yet but based on the trailer it does
look like there's something involving a
train
i'm also glad they brought back the
metal for this scene we haven't had a
good metal saw trap in a while
[Music]
also i can't show it for multiple
obvious reasons but after she's torn in
half by the pain train you can just see
her boobs for half a second
just hanging there on opposite sides
didn't notice that the first couple
times i watched it but uh feel free to
pop in the blu-ray
that's your thing i guess last episode i
pointed out how she still had pictures
of john in her apartment which could be
used to explain why she was willing to
carry out his plan because it looks like
there are still some feelings there
she's got a shot of him by her bedside
too and she still sleeps on one side of
the bed
this movie's all about her trying to
stay safe from hoffman but i don't think
wine and pills are the best way to go
when you're trying to stay alive after
this there's a time skip forward to the
next jigsaw trap and the main victim is
this guy named evan if he looks familiar
it's because he's played by lincoln park
front man chester bennington apparently
one of the guys in his band lived next
door to saw producer mark berg and the
rest is history evan and his friends
would not make it out of this trap
though and so would not get to
participate in the jigsaw survivor
support group which contains a whole
bunch of cameos from characters who
survived in movies past and many of them
look different than they did
during their initial tests
the jigsaw survivor support group brings
together those who managed to escape
their tests dating all the way back from
the first saw to saw seven
they include lawrence gordon the doctor
from the bathroom game and saw
scott malek the arsonist of the fatal
five and saw five
simone the lone shark from the pound of
flesh trap in saw six addie the
receptionist of umbrella health in
sussex
emily one of the policy reviewers from
umbrella health in sussex tara abbott
the widowed mother in six brad and ryan
from the opening of saw seven bobby
dagon who was only pretending to be a
victim to sell books and a new character
named sydney there are a couple of other
new characters as well though we never
learned their names or stories there are
other known survivors who are missing
from this group from saw one we have
jeff reidenhauer allison gordon and
diana gordon from saw two there's daniel
matthews from saw three there's corbett
denlon from saw four
there's the teacher's wife morgan from
saw five we have brit stevenson
from saw six there's brent abbott pamela
jenkins and shelby from saw seven
there's joan the woman who inspired
bobby dagon and from jigsaw there's
logan nelson we get to see the story of
the new character sydney the reason
she's tested
is not clear but the theme of the trap
seems to be
i don't know gardening themed we've got
lawnmowers potted plants some keemstar
merch you're really gonna start killing
people for not mowing the dangled lawn
jigsaw she gets into it a little bit
with the one-handed wonder simone we saw
her in the last movie explode at hoffman
for asking if she learned anything from
jigsaw's test and this time she blows up
on sydney for suggesting that the trap
was the best thing that ever happened to
her
that's a bunch of [ __ ] he had to die
for you to leave him you want to know
the best thing that happened to me
after having to cut off my own arm
his handicap parking at the damn mall
good job simone girl always stands her
ground the location where the group
meets is inside of a church i've talked
in the previous videos about the
religious undertones of jigsaw's
following the survivors of his tests
become his followers and his rules serve
his commandments to them
so them meeting inside of a church is an
interesting decision in that respect
and i know i've said it before but
gordon's part is so hilarious i can't
not play it
i'm sure i speak for everyone here when
i say how
grateful we are to be part of your
promotional dvd
so the metropolitan police department
couldn't get it done the fbi couldn't
get it done so now
with the new jigsaw being hoffman a
police officer it falls on internal
affairs the division that investigates
crimes committed by the police which
raises the question
who investigates the ia because i have a
crime to report gibson you made this way
too obvious did you have to make it that
obvious the main game of saw7 follows
bobby dagon as he tries to save those
close to him as punishment for faking
that he was a jigsaw victim his wife
watches his struggle on the monitor
what's going on what's going on
like do you really not know your husband
wrote a whole book about this
do you seriously not know what's going
on here we see the moment bobby had the
idea to write his book after seeing the
story of a survivor of one of the traps
it gave me light
[Music]
that pure moment of absolute horror gave
me light
and as wrong as this may seem
i'm better for endearing it it's
interesting the way she words it that it
gave her lights because john talks about
the idea of enlightenment for his test
subjects from the very first movie and
lights were used as a symbol of this at
the beginning of each film
as bobby continues down the ikea path he
discovers his own motivational phrases
being mockingly displayed against him we
know this because the title of his book
is an acronym
survive we can't really see the text on
the book cover but if we take the first
letter of the phrases graffiti down the
psychiatric hospital in the order that
they appear it spells out the word
survive
put it all together and you get start
your life anew understand your problems
redefine your priorities verify your
self-worth through commitment
ignore your detractors value your loved
ones embrace every day as if it is your
last there's also a theme that connects
each room
throughout the game bobby's associates
enable his behavior by knowingly
supporting his lie
throughout the series there have been
many examples i've pointed out of jon
pulling ideas from asian culture and the
traps in this game connect to a japanese
legend known as three wise monkeys a
17th century pictorial maxim meant to
teach his audience not to ignore when
they see someone commit a sin the three
monkeys are mizuru translating to see
not hikazaru which means hear not and
iwazaru speak not in the tape for each
of the games in bobby's trial jigsaw
mentions that his associates must speak
no evil hear no evil or see no evil in
order to pass
the first room contains a trap for his
publicist nina
she has been your publicist for years
knowing your lies by choosing to speak
no evil
she has been richly rewarded for her
words
but today she will be rewarded for
her silence and the trap literally
threatens her ability to speak and helps
spread bobby's lies by threatening to
impale her throat if she makes too much
noise before he retrieves the key
this is one of the most frustrating
traps ever because she hears the tape
too
she knows she's not supposed to scream
and yet
i mean is she that dumb does she have a
death wish why does she keep screaming
why would you just shut the thank you
nina was the dumbest victim ever the
next room contains a trap for bobby's
lawyer suzanne
before you is your lawyer who swore an
oath of ethics but chose
to say no you in order to benefit
herself
if bobby could not save her she would be
forced to see no evil because she'd be
impaled in the face with more spikes
probably making her look like a
minecraft creeper and
like the last game why is she screaming
through the entire thing i mean the
dude's obviously trying to help you just
shut up for a minute and let him focus
i'm having a hard time feeling bad for
anyone who died in this movie so far
the third room by default is the hear no
evil room and contains bobby's best
friend
kale across from you is your closest
friend
he knows all your sins yet he acts as
though
he hears no evil today what he hears
will be the difference between life and
death
so bobby has to guide him across the
room using only audible commands
i mean i would have just told him to
stay put and gotten on all fours and
taken the key to him which would have
been way faster and safer but i'm
starting to think bobby's not the
smartest but as this game is going on
the search for hoffman continues and
while this email sent to gibson's office
only appears on screen momentarily there
is a lot of info we can pull from it
hoffman sends a dvd not a promotional
dvd mind you to gibson's supposedly
secret safehouse the disc is named
scene 57 vhs edit 4x3 i wish i could say
this was a callback to the first movie
where we saw the label that says saw
bathroom set and by doing this they're
bringing the series somehow full circle
but this is kind of
inexcusable seven films and seven years
type of stuff with the location of the
safe house compromise
gibson decides to move jill to a holding
cell in the police station for safety he
comes in to ask her a question
interrupting her reading this blank book
do you know this guy hoffman sends
another video this time over email and
if we pause on the screen there are a
few things to note the most recent email
is obviously from detective hoffman but
the one before that is from soren papa
scale those of you who have been
following all of my things you missed in
saw episodes will remember that soren is
the first assistant art director of
these movies but his name has appeared
as an easter egg in saw five and saw six
so i've been piecing together a
backstory for him based on the previous
appearances of his name we determined
he was a doctor from norway who was a
victim of a crime while visiting the us
seeing as how he's now sending files to
matt gibson of internal affairs i would
have to say that the crime committed
against him must have been committed by
the police maybe he was subject to some
eric matthews police brutality the other
guy emailing gibson is brent mcgillivray
this is the first time we've seen that
name and he's credited as first
assistant art director and set designer
in the other column here we can see
hoffman's email address now i know
there's a lot of debate in the saw
fandom on whether or not hoffman is
alive so why don't we just send him an
email and ask him
to m hoffman at metro dot poll mark just
wanted to email you to confirm whether
or not you are in fact
still alive please email me back if you
are not dead thanks
i'll let you guys know if he gets back
to me below hoffman's email address we
have the date it's march 12th
saw five and six took place in july 2006
and we can assume jill's dream took
place in the winter on account of all
the snow
so the march 12th date puts us in early
2007 which checks out nicely with the
2007 calendar that we saw at the auto
body shop
under that we see gibson's email address
might as well send him something too
m gibson at metro dot poll hey gibson i
know you're now dead but i just wanted
to say you were the only good cop
besides carrie
and she's also dead rest in peace man
rest in peace the email content reminds
gibson of an event from their past where
hoffman saved his life by mercilessly
shooting a junkie
i had no choice but to report often from
brutality they end up finding the secret
room in the auto body shop behind the
bathroom mirror this might be a
reference to candyman where the two
apartments are connected by mirror in a
similar fashion but could also just be a
callback to saw 5 and the hidden doorway
seen in that movie
they end up finding hoffman and john's
notes about the victims for this game
and they give us a little bit more
insight into how john's assistants are
always able to find and kidnap the
victim so easily there are detailed
notes about their daily routines their
personal information
where they can be found even specifics
about their alarm codes and computer
passwords
bobby's final test is to do what he lied
about having done in his book by
impaling his pecs with meat hooks and
hoisting himself up
this has got to be the dumbest trap yet
i mean just put your feet on the smooth
part of these hooks and then pull
yourself up that way or just climb the
chain or something this is literally the
dumbest way to go about this
naturally he fails and as a result his
wife has to pay the price for some
reason it doesn't really say why she was
a part of this but i think we can assume
it has something to do with the fact
that she was only interested in him for
his fame
her punishment is a modern day version
of the brazen bull a torture device
execution chamber depicted in renderings
from ancient greece in which a person
was placed inside of a hollowed bronze
bowl and a fire was ignited underneath
thereby roasting the person
not in the way i might roast my
opponents in rocket league but actually
roasting them like the way you might
roast your shawarma before sticking it
in a pita and drizzling over tahini
sauce to stay on the mediterranean theme
of this trap the saw version of the
brazen bowl seems to be more shaped like
a brazen pig keeping up with the theme
of pigs that has come up time and time
again in this franchise
like the pendulum trap from the fifth
movie there is some debate as to whether
or not the brazen bull actually ended up
becoming a real thing
and that's the last we see of bobby
dagan i mean i guess he's most likely
still alive i personally like to see him
write another book
the police realized that hoffman tapped
into their security system he's been
watching
us the whole time i think it's not so
much that he's a hacker but more that
he's a cop and i guess they forgot to
revoke his access after realizing that
he's bad
or maybe he's actually a hacker i mean
who even knows at this point hoffman had
hidden himself in one of the body bags
being transported back to the station
and the first person he encounters is
the coroner this is meaningful for
hoffman because this was the same guy
that discovered that a different knife
was used to cut the jigsaw piece from
seth baxter which is what led to hoffman
being caught by the fbi in the previous
movie forcing him to hide out for eight
months
he then goes on a rampage taking out
nearly the entire police station in
pursuit of jill tuck
i'll be looking for you if we pause as
jill grabs something to defend herself
with it looks to be part of a nail file
kit there's also an article about
lowering the cost of healthcare by
moving to canada though i guess that one
would be more appropriate in
saw six she's able to get away if only
temporarily and scrambles to hide in the
evidence room and in the background of
nearly every shot in there we can spot
old traps newspaper headlines design
sketches and
more things you missed
[Music]
after following the journeys of
countless law enforcement officers in
their conquest to put an end to the
jigsaw killings it is only fitting that
we near the conclusion of the saw saga
by finally paying a visit to the main
evidence room but fans may choose to see
it as more of a shrine to almost
everything we have come to know over the
course of this 7 movie journey
as hoffman comes in and turns on the
lights there's a collection of newspaper
clippings and magazine covers
including this one police injured during
jigsaw raid which details the beginning
of the invasion at wilson's steel plant
from the beginning of saw two
on the top shelf of this thing you'll
see the head cage that we saw in john's
workshop in saw two but was never used
from that same workshop is this photo on
the back wall which corresponds to the
face mask trap that i theorized to be
possibly an early version of the oxygen
crusher
and this giant clamp was the device that
crushed the janitor hang
just imagine the whole thing being
rotated so that the clamps are reaching
out towards us
up in the corner maybe the oxygen tanks
used in that trap
hoffman also sees a mannequin from the
mannequin factory on stygian street in
saw one where jon narrowly evaded singh
and tat
another mannequin is seen on the other
side of the room there's also a cart
with the scale used in the pound of
flesh trap the opener from saw six
the headgear from the pound of flesh is
sitting on a shelf on the other side of
the room and the tubes that they had to
send their offerings down to reach the
scales are sitting behind the desk
just beyond the scale is the
hydrofluoric acid injection rack from
the rowan zoological institute also from
sussex
also from the zoo is the little cage
that william easton had to put his hand
into to determine who lives and who dies
during the infamous shotgun carousel
trap
these big gears appear to be the
components that held up the giant ice
blocks that eventually crushed eric
matthews in saw4
over to the right behind the wall we can
see part of the rack from saw three
in front of the wall is a cage
containing four shotguns these are the
quadruple shotguns that got detective
singh in saw one
the chair that hoffman grabs is
fittingly the chair from the end of the
last movie that jill set up to shock him
when he sat down
of course who could possibly forget the
good old classics hoffman passes on the
reverse bear trap 2.0 that jill left him
to die in at the end of the previous
movie and ops for the saw one original
on the left wall there are more articles
and evidence photos including a very
dapper looking shot of young billy when
he was doing the whole pete wentz look
which is right above the photo of john
and art blank at the opening of gideon
meat packing plant if you look
all the way to the right partially
obscured by the walls you'll see the
water cube trap that almost drowned
agent strom in saw 5.
i'm not entirely sure about this because
the lighting is different but the device
seen on top of the card on the right
here may be the spinal contraption that
art blank had to wear during his
test in soft4 and these wheels could
really be a number of things but they
may be the device that jon used to
manipulate the audio in his tapes
we see it in flashback and software so
that's the evidence room and that's the
saw saga i do feel like i may not have
gotten every little thing so let me know
if you caught any other references in
the comments the sauce series was
thought to be over
after the release of saw7 in 2010 but
like many horror icons jigsaw could not
be kept off the silver screen and the
franchise would return with jigsaw in
click the video on the left to see what
you might have missed in that eighth
installment and be sure to subscribe
because i think it may be time to give
that video a revisit and offer up a few
new things you missed make sure you ring
the death bell for notifications and
i'll see you in the next one
assuming we both survive
[Music]
hoffman never emailed me back so guess
he's dead